[Music]
[Music]
this is a story about clothing
it's about the clothes we wear
the people who make these clothes
and the impact that it's having on our
world
it's a story about greed and fear
power
and poverty
it's complex as it extends all the way
around the world
but it's also simple
revealing just how connected we are to
the many hearts and hands behind our
clothes
[Music]
i came into this story with no
background in fashion at all
beginning with nothing more than a few
simple questions
what i've discovered has forever changed
the way i think about the things i wear
and my hope
is that it might just do the same
for you
maybe just start and say your name and
talk about how this kind of began my
name is lucy siegel i am a journalist
and broadcaster based in the uk
and i have been obsessed consumed with
the environmental and social impacts of
the fashion industry
for about a decade
well i love everything about clothes you
know i love i love the poetry i love the
fabric i love the colors i love the
textures i love the way that they make
you feel you know they are
our chosen skin
well i had the classic
massive closet clothes everywhere
bags constantly coming into my house you
know every day every other day with some
other item in and never had anything to
wear i could never put together a
coherent outfit
we communicate who we are to a certain
extent through clothing and this is this
is again throughout history you know you
have the transit court you know again
marie antoinette making these huge hats
it's always been it's our personal
communication in many ways that's what
interests me that it is fundamentally a
part of what
we wish to communicate about ourselves
[Music]
and we used to have a system a fashion
system where people would go to the
shows so they would do spring summer
autumn winter and those kind of ran like
clockwork for very many years okay rip
that up throw it out the window that has
absolutely nothing to do with the
fashion industry today it has been
reinvented
the shift is moving
ruthlessly
towards
a way of producing which
only really
looks after
big business interest
growing up i never gave much thought to
anything other than the price of the
clothes that i bought
usually making choices based on the
style or a good deal
looking back i learned that for a long
time most of our clothing was actually
made right here in america
as recently as the 1960s we were still
making 95 of our clothes
today we only make about 3
and the other 97 is outsourced to
developing countries around the world
[Music]
i've been in the business for over nine
years now in terms of scale we got about
25 000 people just on government
manufacturing side we produce one in six
dressers sold in the us
if you actually go to a store and you
benchmark the price of a garment over
the last 20 years
you will find that it's actually a
deflationary product like the price has
gone down over time now has our cost
going down absolutely not okay the cost
has gone up
the more production we've outsourced the
cheaper prices have become on the
clothing we buy
making way for a whole new model known
as fast fashion
almost overnight transforming the way
clothing is bought and sold
the newest h m store on fifth avenue in
manhattan is the company's largest ever
and just one of many new stores it's
planning around the country it's all
part of a high street revolution fast
fashion instead of two seasons a year we
practically have 52 seasons a year so we
have something new coming in every week
and fast fashion has created this so
that it can essentially shift more
products
[Music]
you can get this fridge metallic skirt
for 39 at joe fresh a brand new store in
town with price tags that might look a
little bit more appealing to budget
conscious shoppers american consumers
they really have grasped the fashion
part of h m and we know from before that
american consumers are very
value-oriented if you match these two
together with fashion and value then you
have a recipe one japanese clothing
retailer is making a fast and furious
march here in the u.s the price has
dropped the way of making that product
has completely completely changed and
you have to ask yourself at some point
where does it end
the global marketplace is some place
where we export work to have happen in
whatever conditions we want and then the
products come back to me cheap enough to
throw away without thinking about it
well globalized production
basically means that all of the making
of goods has been outsourced to low-cost
economies particularly where wages are
very low and kept low and what that
means is that those at the top of the
value chain they get to choose where the
products are being made and they get to
switch if for example one factory says
we can't make it that cheap anymore
the brand will say well we're not going
to come to you anymore we're going to
switch to another place which is cheaper
in the west they're using everyday low
price
so every day they're empowering me and
i'm hampering my workers this is how it
is
they are competing the stores are
competing in there when the stores are
coming to us for order and negotiating
they're telling look that particular
store is selling this shirt with like
five dollars so i needed to sell it in
the four dollar
so you better squeeze your price so we
are squeezing then other store is coming
and selling hey they're selling it the
four dollar so the target price is three
if you can make the three you are
getting business otherwise you are not
getting
because we want that business so badly
and we don't have other options
okay
every time we are trying to survive
actually
ultimately something is going to give
either the price of the product has to
go up
or
manufacturers have to shut down or cut
corners to make it work
cutting corners and disregarding safety
measures had become an accepted part of
doing business in this new model until
an early morning in april when an event
just outside of dhaka bangladesh brought
a hidden side of fashion to front page
news state media and bangladesh say an
eight-story building has collapsed near
the capital of dhaka killing more than
70 people
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rescue workers are racing against time
searching through the rubble trying to
find as many survivors as they can
hundreds are dead hundreds more might
still be buried alive after officials in
bangladesh say factory owners ignored
and ordered to evacuate some 400 dead
hundreds still believed to be missing
garment workers in bangladesh paying the
price for cheap clothing a huge crowd
has gathered near the building side many
of them family members looking for loved
ones and they say they can still hear
people screaming from underneath the
rubble crying out for help many are
simply losing hope
[Music]
foreign
anybody
who
like me had written about
problems in the supply chain
particularly for fast fashion
and tried to articulate
how
the risk was being carried by those who
are most vulnerable
and the worst paid
you try to articulate that but you could
never have envisaged that there would be
such a catastrophic illustration of what
you were trying to say and rana plaza to
me was like some horror story
two weeks after the catastrophe and the
death toll now stands at a staggering
931 making it the worst garment industry
disaster in history i think one of the
the most
profoundly impressing things about the
rana plaza disaster was that news that
the workers had already pointed out to
the management the cracks in the
building had they'd already printed out
that the building was structurally
unsafe and yet they've been forced back
in
many survivors are asking how they could
have been forced to return to work when
management already was aware of the
cracks in the building and workers
concerns on the very day of the collapse
a lot of clothes in american stores are
made in bangladesh by workers who earn
about two dollars a day
last month there a garment factory
collapsed killing more than 1 000 and a
few months before that a factory fire
killed more than 100. and his bodies are
still being pulled out of the rubble
another factory in bangladesh caught
fire early this morning killing eight
more people
as story after story of clothing factory
disasters kept filling the news it was
now the case that three of the four
worst tragedies in the history of
fashion had all happened in the last
year
as the death toll rose so did the
profits generated the year following the
disaster at rana plaza was the
industry's most profitable of all time
the global fashion industry is now an
almost three trillion dollar annual
industry bangladesh is now the second
largest apparel exporter after china how
well unlike some of its competitors
bangladeshi manufacturing remains dirt
cheap and unions have limited power the
country cornered the absolute bottom of
the value chain
those 1000
poor girls lost their life because
everybody didn't
bother didn't give
damn [ __ ] and they just wanted the cheap
price and a good profit it shouldn't be
like that
everybody should take the responsibility
for those kids
that's how it is
and it might coming coming more sorry
but
yeah you know that it's not only the
price pressure it's
something ignoring other people's life
is it's it's it's not it should it it's
not right it's 21st century
it's a global world we are living and we
just ignore other people's life
how come
this enormous
rapacious industry that is generating so
much profit for a handful of people
why is it that it is unable
to support
millions of its workers properly
why is it that it is not able to
guarantee their safety we're talking
about essential human rights
why is it unable to guarantee that
whilst generating these tremendous
profits is it because it doesn't work
properly that is my question
lucy's question sounds like the obvious
one but instead of answering it
everywhere i looked i found people who
were constantly justifying the cost
because of the economic benefits being
generated
so
this low-wage manufacturing or so-called
sweat shops they're not just the least
bad option workers have today they're
part of the very process that raises
living standards and leads to higher
wages and better working conditions over
time your proximate causes of
development are physical capital
technology and human capital or skills
of the workers when sweatshops come to
these countries they bring all three of
those to these workers and start getting
that process going is it possible that
sweatshops are actually good yes
horrible awful sweatshops the word
itself sweatshop it evokes terrible
images of poor people and children
suffering in third world countries
slaving away in awful conditions to make
products
for us selfish americans and thank you
what
does it does it bother me that people
are working in a factory making clothes
for
americans or for you know europeans or
that they're that's how they're spending
their lives
is that what you're kind of asking me um
yeah sure
um
no i mean you know
they're doing a job there are a lot
worse things that they can be doing it
is live television and i will ask you
define sweatshops yeah i think we have
to be very clear what we're talking
about from the outset so we're talking
about places with very poor working
conditions as us normal americans would
experience it very low wages by our
standard maybe children working places
that might not obey local labor laws but
there's a key characteristics of the
type of ones i want to talk to you about
tonight kennedy and that's that there
are places where people choose to work
admittedly from a bad set of other
options well i mean there's nothing
intrinsically dangerous with sewing
clothes
so we're kind of starting out with you
know with a relatively safe industry
it's not like coal mining or
natural gas mining or you know a lot of
things that you can
that are much more dangerous so
sweatshops jobs look like horrible
working conditions and wages to anybody
in the west who's wealthy enough to own
a tv and watch your video
but we have to keep in mind that the
alternatives available for these workers
aren't our own alternatives they're much
worse than our alternatives and they're
usually much worse than the factory job
that the worker has
low wages
unsafe conditions and factory disasters
are all excused because of the needed
jobs they create for people with no
alternatives
this story has become the narrative
used to explain the way the fashion
industry now operates all over the world
but there are those who believe that
there must be a better way of making and
selling clothing that does generate
economic growth but without taking such
an enormous toll
so we don't know yet um
how long this embroidery is taking do
you think you could ask chantu just yeah
just roughly
how long that whole panel is taking
because i guess we'll see it later on in
the fab price breakdown but it would be
great to know wouldn't it so i'm safier
mini i'm founder and ceo of peopletree
and uh peopletree is a fair trade
fashion brand that started over 20 years
ago in japan
you were worried that we had a bit too
much navy what are you feeling now
because we did put more black into ss14
and that has worked really really well
with um
allah's um designer collaboration have
we got enough black print in the
collection uh well we've lost that
abstract
dust print this one here
in the black but i think this paint
could be really i think it's one of
those prints that everyone's a bit
nervous of but actually will do well
i think most fashion brands start with a
concept of a collection or a look
um they don't tend to think uh you know
who is going to make the product and
how can i ensure that
producers or or suppliers
are going to eat
um so what we're trying to do at
peopletree is really start with
the skills that we have at each producer
group and then design the collection up
whilst also looking at the integrity of
the collection
in its aesthetic
i worked originally with freelance
designers and went into bangladesh
zimbabwe india nepal the philippines
and bit by bit we put together you know
an amazing network of like-minded fair
trade organizations that put
women's development you know the workers
social development and environment
absolutely central to everything they do
one two three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's beautiful fair trade is a
citizen's response to correcting the
social injustice in an international
trading system that is largely
dysfunctional where
workers and farmers are not paid
a living wage
and where the environment is is not
considered at all to make the products
that we buy every day
[Music]
shima is one of about 40 million garment
factory workers in the world
almost 4 million of these workers are
here in bangladesh working in almost 5
000 factories making clothing for major
western brands
over 85 percent of these workers are
women and with a minimum wage of less
than three dollars a day they are among
the lowest paid garment workers in the
world
you're going to have
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the workers
must not have any kind of distrust on
their own
if they have there will not be any good
working atmosphere in the factory
they must respect
our owner
is paying us
as per rule
if they do not have this kind of
confidence you won't get the results
in
it's estimated that one in every six
people alive in the world today
work in some part of the global fashion
industry
making it the most labor-dependent
industry on earth
most of this work is done by people like
shima who have no voice in the larger
supply chain
but to fully understand the impact that
fashion is having on our world we have
to go back
to where it all begins
my grandparents settled out here in the
20s and so this is a part of my heritage
people ask why i'm an organic cotton
farm it's because i don't know any
better my granddaddy was an old german
farmer that felt like we should respect
the land we're stewards of the land and
we spread the life that's in the land
you're actually sitting in
the high plains of texas and there's 3.6
million acres of cotton grown in this
region we're literally the biggest
cotton patch in the world
in just the past 10 years 80 percent of
that is now gmo genetically modified
cotton
most of it is roundup ready meaning that
instead of the farmers spot spraying
weeds occasionally in their field or
hiring laborers to walk the field and
eliminate the weeds now they're
spraying whole fields
cotton produces the fiber that's
responsible for most of the clothing
worn by the world today
and as our appetite for fashion grows
the cotton plant itself is being
re-engineered to keep up there's been
this big drive towards the
industrialization of agriculture the
intensification of agriculture so
instead of the old forms of farming
which were very much in tune with nature
they were they were linked to the cycles
of the natural year and the seasons what
you see now is an intensification where
the land is almost reconsidered as if it
was a factory
what you've created is this general
practice of we treat
millions of acres
the same we put a dose of chemical on it
all
and that's when you get these big
ecological effects
that nobody has a grasp of what's really
happening
nature tends to heal itself in small
pockets
but when you get this
big broad approach
we really don't know what's going on for
us
it's not reducing the amount of
pesticides and chemicals that are going
on the cotton that's one of the big
sales that reduces that not in our area
where we are spraying
millions and millions of acres and
dollars of roundup across the entire
south plains
what kind of impact is that having on
our soil with residual
residuals that are left at the micro
bacterial level what kind of impact is
that having on the people in our
communities where's the cost on that
monsanto is proud to be the industry
leader in agricultural innovation
because of what these agricultural
advancements can do to help you double
yields for the future needs of the world
we're dedicated to the future of
agriculture and providing farmers with
innovations that help them produce more
and conserve more
while improving the lives of people
around the world
together we can face the challenges of
the next generation
and beyond
[Music]
after the wars where all these redundant
factories that made more chemicals
explosives
were lying around
the western countries
thought
that it would be a good idea to
market them to the third world after all
the same industry that makes explosives
makes nitrogen fertilizers
and they started to push nitrogen
fertilizers
from the 50s onwards after we became
independent but the
nitrogen fertilizers don't do very well
with native crops there's a problem of
lodging
so the whole system
then organized itself to redesign the
plant
in order to take on more chemicals
bt cotton is a cotton in which a gene
has been added from a bacteria to
produce a toxin
but the bt cotton
which is supposed to control a pest
has been offered
because it's a way for companies to own
the seed
by patenting these genetically modified
plants monsanto has become the largest
seed and chemical corporation in history
i wanted to speak with someone who had
worked with the company and i got word
that a former managing director for
india was willing to talk one of my
close friends who was in the research
division working on these modified crops
he came to my hotel for a drink
he was sitting having a drink and after
a few drinks he told me hey jack
we're going to change
type of business you are doing in india
i said what you mean
we are going to get into seeds business
and
we are going to make the seed business
of all crops
so that we have the monopoly and seeds
and
every farmers come to us to buy seeds
every time
that rang a bell in my mind
if a four farmers go to monsanto to buy
seeds every time
and such expensive seeds
at the time there is no idea of bt at
all for me gently motivates it was not
in my mind
even seed monopoly is something very bad
so farmers get into debt when they get
the seed because of the high cost 17 000
more
they get into deeper debt because it
doesn't deliver on the promise of
controlling pests so they have to buy
more pesticides
the tragedy with chemicals whether it's
fertilizers or pesticides is that they
are what has been called ecological
narcotics the more you use them the more
you need to use them for a while the
yield of the single commodity climbs and
then it starts to decline because you
have contaminated
the soil
most of india's cotton is grown in the
punjab region
which has quickly become the largest
user of pesticides in india
dr prit paul singh has been studying the
effects of these chemicals on human
health and his reports show a dramatic
rise in the number of birth defects
cancers and mental illness here in the
region
you can go in every village you will see
that
hundreds of patients are suffering
with the cancers 70 to 80 80 80 kids in
every village will find the mentors
facing the severement retardation and
physical handicapping
[Music]
[Music]
companies fertilizer pesticides they are
totally uh refusing the after effects of
the pacific fertilizer and this is the
uh you can say classical uh symptoms of
the toxicity in one village there is
sixty mental targeted kids like this
this war
so it will be very
dangerous phenomena
uh in in the punjab
and
pupils farmers and labor there is a
small farmers and
maximum deliverments so they can't
afford now treatment ultimately they
have accept to the death of their kids
and they are waiting the death of their
kids mother is waiting for the death of
this boy
companies that make this
gm seeds and make the chemicals are the
same companies and they also the same
companies that make the medicines which
they are not patented so you get cancer
they are more profits for them it's a
win-win-win-win-win
as for nature and people to lose those
those lose
it's the day those agents of these
companies come to the farmer and say
you owe me this much you haven't paid
back now your land is my land
that day the farmer will go into his
field
drink a bottle of pesticide and end his
life and every widow i've talked to said
and the neighbors came and said they
first found my husband lying in the
field
in the last 16 years there have been
more than 250 000 recorded farmer
suicides in india
that's about one farmer every 30 minutes
and it's the largest recorded wave of
suicides in history
[Music]
as it becomes clear just how much of an
impact fashion is having on our world
there is an increasing amount of
research to suggest that it's also
having a growing effect on us
the people buying these clothes
what we now know 20 years later and
hundreds of studies later is that the
more that people are focused on those
materialistic values the more that they
say that money and image and status and
possessions are important to them the
less happy they are the more depressed
they are the more anxious they are we
know that all of these kinds of
psychological problems tend to go up as
materialistic values go up now that's
really at odds with the thousands of
messages that we receive every day from
advertisements suggesting that
materialism and the pursuit of
possessions and owning stuff is what's
going to make us happy it's important to
understand that advertising is a species
or a category of propaganda
we think of propaganda as a totalitarian
thing very grim
loudspeakers you know chanting crowds
and so on we think of hitler we always
think of of it as a foreign thing okay
but it's actually as american as apple
pie
well the reason that advertising works
is because the smart advertisers at
least are trying to tie the consumption
of their product
to
a message that suggests that your needs
will be satisfied
by consuming this thing it wants you to
believe that you'll look wonderful in
that thing
but then to put it on and feel like nah
you look kind of fat in it you don't
look that good and you're sorry you
bought it but there's another one you
can find
[Music]
[Music]
i'm more than a maker
[Music]
so think of all of the car commercials
you see that show
well i've really made it now i'm a
competent person because i'm driving
this bmw or this audi or think of all
the shampoo commercials you've seen
where the person now has beautiful
flowing hair and is loved and
appreciated by the people around them
the basic message is the same the way to
solve the problems of your life we all
have problems in our life the way to
solve the problem in your life is
through consumption hey you guys today
i'm coming to you guys with a clothing
haul i went shopping a couple days ago
and literally went insane and bought so
many things my spam box i don't know
where is literally blown up by you guys
saying you guys wanted a haul
so
here it is okey-dokey so first off i
have some things that i got from h m so
then i went to forever 21. it wasn't
even a question it was just like fate i
just had to get it like if it could
levitate towards me it would have
levitated i got this skirt
bright yellow and it was
8.50
it's a jean button-up
thing and i just love this i just loved
it loved it loved it it's a gray knit
sweater and it has pink hearts all over
it i lived i loved highlight things like
tie-dye things are literally the
bomb.net it has a little yingyang sign
on the front of it i just love these so
much and it's just this really pretty
light blue sweater i don't even know if
i'm gonna wear this now that i got it
because i don't know if i like it that
much i need to stop
i try to understand better why people
don't realize that they are becoming
poorer and poorer and i ask myself okay
but what has changed inspect of when i
was young and fashion is something that
has dramatically changed i was able to
buy
one two t-shirts four shirt for example
a year now
i mean also my children they used to buy
every every party i mean they buy a
t-shirt and so i understood that the
fast fashion is something totally new if
you have noticed
the price has decreased in the last
years
and it does follow
the middle class disappearing so all the
things that people really need
are very costs are very costly like
home like study like life insurance
on the other side there is a sort of
consolation
part of their life i can
buy a t-shirt two t-shirts a party or
eventually a day
although i'm very poor and i've got lost
i've lost all the things i really needed
today we purchase over 80 billion pieces
of new clothing each year that's 400
more than the amount we bought just two
decades ago the way we buy clothes has
changed so much so fast that few people
have actually stepped back to understand
the origin of this new model or the
consequence of such an unprecedented
increase in consumption there is um
an article in printers inc
which is the leading advertising trade
journal of of its day
by a very famous copywriter named ernest
elmo calkins grand old man of uh the art
of writing advertising copy
there's an article called consumptionism
in that article he says there are there
are two
kinds of products
okay they're the kind that you use
like washing machines cars and so on
things that you buy
and use for a long time
and then there are the things that you
use up
like chewing gum and cigarettes other
perishables
he said
consumptionism is all about getting
people to treat the things they use
as the things they use up
with their innovative buy one get three
free pricing a zoo from joseph a bank is
effectively cheaper than paper towels
and now they come with these easy to use
dispensers
with four suits for the price of a
modest dinner i can feel good about
throwing them away when i'm done
you just have to look at landfill and
you can see in landfill that the amount
of clothes and textiles being chucked
away has been increasing steadily over
the last 10 years
as the sort of dirty shadow of the fast
fashion industry
as we get sort of closer and closer to
species degradation to
trashing our last remaining pristine
wilderness we seem hell-bent on
producing more and more disposable stuff
it makes no sense fashion should never
and can never be thought of as a
disposable product
i think after any big change in any
industry it takes a while to sort of to
feel and smell the dirt that comes out
of something
that is that is polluting so i think now
there is a change because
you can't deny
that the fast fashion industry is having
a massive impact in developing countries
the average american throws away 82
pounds of textile waste each year adding
up to more than 11 million tons of
textile waste from the u.s alone most of
this waste is non-biodegradable meaning
it sits in landfills for 200 years or
more while releasing harmful gases into
the air
the sheer amount of cheap clothing
even though people feel perhaps somehow
um that they're offsetting by giving to
charity you know the journey of a
t-shirt donated to charity is
unpalatable in itself
peppa
um
it is a disease in haiti and not only in
haiti i think i can earn any total world
country that you're visiting like you
know it's a problem it's a huge problem
pepe
a bunch of clothes
most of them came from the states
people will go and buy a box full of
clothes they don't even know what
they're buying
those are clothes
people donate to charity
and charity cannot sell them on their
trip store or whatever
they pack them
ship them
to those third country
and most of them end up here turns out
that only about 10 percent of the
clothes that we donate actually get sold
and
here has disappeared
once a proud local tailoring sector
haiti now produces mostly cheap t-shirts
for export to america
foreign
[Music]
so i'll tell people stop buying things
that is not good that is constantly like
you know 10 hours you're going to go on
a on a ball you're going out today you
just go to a store and buy yourself a
dress for ten dollars because like you
know it cost ten dollars i don't even
throw it away
and tomorrow you're going to do the same
thing over and over and over again
as awareness of fashion's impact on our
world is growing there are key leaders
in the industry who are beginning to
question the impacts of a model built on
careless production and endless
consumption
patagonia we hate the word
consumers
it's
we've got to find a better word we
prefer customers and we prefer also
customers who recognize the impact of
their consumption they recognize that
as consumers they're part of the problem
we
are hopeful that we can encourage our
customers to join us in really
questioning consumption because without
a reduction in consumption we don't feel
that we'll really collectively find a
solution to the problems we face that
are collectively
year by year uh resulting in the
continued decline of the health of our
planet
i mean the fashion industry just needs
to think
it needs to just stop and sort of look
at how it's been
working in a conventional way and just
sort of question it challenge it you
know and that's for me as a designer
that's the most exciting thing that i do
now
more exciting than saying oh i love this
color this season or this is the
silhouette or the hemline for me way a
way bigger challenge and excitement is
actually looking at my industry and
saying you know what i'm gonna try and
do it in a way that is not as harmful to
the planet
business through advertising has uh has
pulled society
along into this belief
that uh happiness is based on stuff that
uh true happiness can only be achieved
with uh you know
an annual
seasonal weekly daily increase in the
amount of stuff you bring into your life
that that we want to encourage our
customers to to think twice about those
assumptions to understand where they
came from and through that understanding
to know that we can all together we can
change how this is done the customer has
to know
that they're in charge without them we
don't have jobs you know and that is
really important so you don't have to
buy into it if you don't like it you
don't have to buy into it
[Music]
i love the embroidery shantu
the boiler is really nice don't you
think we should have the embroidery on
both sides i think we should definitely
add the embroidery here as well
i think it looks a bit mean to have it
just on the front so let's have it on
the sides too
it won't add much cost it's not so dense
is it
swallows is a fair trade
fashion business but it's also a
development society so it helps more
than 3 000 people in this village
i come here every four months
we call them production trips and um and
we're working with the producers trying
to find out you know what are the
barriers to making a great product and
to to getting it to the market and we're
also doing fair trade capacity building
so looking at you know what what are the
obstacles to delivering more social
benefit or improving you know the
environmental protection in the in these
areas for me this this is about
partnering this is about finding
creative solutions together with them
with the team here
and really listening to what their
problems are and finding a way that
works together
i want to invite um the best employee
here at swallows i want to invite one
woman one female representative from
swallows to come to london
in autumn or next spring
and i would like you to think who would
be that best representative
but i want you to know who your
customers are and i want you to really
understand the marketplace and come back
and tell all your friends
[Music]
either if she does it single thread
single stitch then maybe she needs to do
more densely okay more concentrated
singles
[Music]
[Music]
can she come and show us the next
one that she does
i kind of hope that people she wouldn't
be necessary and i hoped that
you know we would have a trading system
that looked after people's rights and
the environment and
but the more and more involved i got in
developing and working closely with
partners the more
you know dirt and filth i discovered
about how trading practices undermine
everything that we believe in and
everything
i know
most people believe in value
i don't know people she just really grew
organically it grew from
a really great collection of people that
feel passionately that there's a
different way of
of of working of living of consuming of
you know interacting with people about
humane way
and
you know i mean i didn't necessarily
feel that there'd be a thousand shops
selling people trees a day um
and i see there's so much more that we
need to do so i think it's not just
about you know creating jobs for the 7
000 people that work for peopletree it's
also about being a catalyst for change
you know within the industry and showing
proving the model works
yeah when we were first in organic i
think there was only two or three of us
at the time we formed the texas organic
cotton marketing cooperative
and the deal was they'd grow it and i'd
sell it so started going to like jacob
javits and having this whole dill cotton
plants and everything and
of yeah we've got organic cotton and
people would just look at us like we
were absolutely crazy
many times consumers become aware of
organic milk or they have an allergy
and so interestingly enough cotton and
what they put on their body even though
the skin's the largest organ on your
body isn't even on their radar screen
because they're not getting the
connection of oh i eat this organic
apple therefore i'm not directly
ingesting pesticides or chemicals or
whatever the case may be but they don't
get that direct connection with clothing
and so you have to start looking that in
that bigger community scope that it is
about our air it's about our world it's
about our planet it's about our people
and so it is that awareness of
you may not feel that you're having the
direct impact by buying this organic
shirt
but the impact you're having
is in the bigger picture in the world at
large and especially in the community
where the cotton's grown
as the hard freeze comes as organic
farmers we wait for that freeze because
that literally defoliates uh takes the
leaves off the plant
so that when we harvest where the bowls
open that are mature
and it leaves the cotton here and you
can see it kind of comes out in sections
so this machine that's coming is called
the cotton stripper
and it's called a cotton stripper
because it literally comes along and
strips
used kind of fingers and it literally
strips
all of the bowls off of this this plant
so when you look over there you can see
the office has been there and it's taken
all the plants off
i think one of the problems that we have
in the current model is it's all about
the profit
and it doesn't take into consideration
at this cost at what cost the cost of
polluting the water the cost of labor
the cost of bars on the window that
people die when a fire breaks out in the
factory the cost of farmers that don't
have access to education and health care
and so we haven't really factored in
what the true cost is
kanpur is situated along river ganga
which is the holiest river
and it's also very important for 800
million hindus and also it serves as
lifeline of north india so this river is
being polluted and killed by the leather
factories of kanpur
with growing demand for materials like
cheap leather kanpur is now the leather
export capital of india
every day here more than 50 million
liters of toxic wastewater pour out of
the local tanneries
heavy chemicals used to treat the
leather like chromium-6 flow into local
farming and even drinking water
in places like kanpur
far from the eyes of the world major
western brands are able to source cheap
materials while avoiding all
accountability for the growing cost to
human health
and the environment
[Music]
people in that area
are in the tight grip of tannery
pollution the local environment is
contaminated
soil is contaminated
the only drinking water source
groundwater is contaminated with
chromium
agricultural produce even vegetables and
salad items are
produced there people's
health are affected
people have different kinds of dermal
problems
skin rashes boils but shoes even
numbness in the limbs people have
established ailments maybe they have
cancers also so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can have the best of materials
moving into the high-end fashion market
in milan or paris or london
but there has been so much of work which
has gone behind it and so much of
chemicals has gone into it the fluents
have been discharged into so many rivers
but we are only looking at that point of
time into the finished product
we need to step back and think about it
fashion today is the number two most
polluting industry on earth second only
to the oil industry
the alarming thing is that not only is
fashion using a huge amount of natural
resources and creating staggering
environmental impacts these natural
resources and this impact is often not
even measured because they've been so
abundant these resources
it's been assumed that they're going to
be there forever
so i think business has not accounted
for them because
it's only since the 1950s that we've
really had this industrial
expansion at such a rate that we started
to see exponential
growth
and exponential use of natural resources
the first economy on which our lives
rest is nature's economy nature has an
economy
that economy is huge it's not counted
then we have people's economy women
working we was working farmers growing
and that was made invisible through this
construct first in the depression and
then during the war years
of the number called the gdp the gross
domestic product which measures
only that
which is traded
and has become a commodity
a lot of the resources that we use to
make our
clothing are not accounted for in the
the cost
of producing those clothes
so when it has
water
that's used to produce clothing land
that's used to grow the fiber
chemicals that are used to die
those things
all are inputs
and
as inputs they cost something
and they also give outputs in some cases
good outputs the clothing themselves
jobs but in other cases bad outputs
like harmful chemicals or greenhouse gas
emissions and those things have costs as
well
foreign
foreign
the same low wages that have made places
like bangladesh so attractive for brands
to do business
have left millions of workers here
working incredibly long hours unable to
afford to keep their children with them
even in the city's worst slums
in order to give their children an
education and the chance of a better
future than life in the factories many
garment workers here like shima are
leaving their children to be raised by
family or friends in villages outside
the city only getting to see them once
or twice a year
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know we are actually profiting from
their
need to work to use them as slaves and
i'm not saying that we don't you know we
need to give them work but it has they
have to be treated
with the same respect that we treat our
children our friends they're not
different from us
olivia firth has been calling for major
change in the fashion industry
she made headlines by starting something
called the green carpet challenge urging
celebrities and top designers to take
part in more mindful forms of fashion
she runs a sustainability consulting
firm called eco-age and had just been
invited to speak at a conference on the
future of fashion if fast fashion didn't
exist
we wouldn't need to have a summit in
copenhagen to try and clean the mess of
environmental destruction social justice
destruction
that it has been caused in the last 15
to 20 years of his existence
fast fashion wants to produce fast
so the garment worker has to produce
faster
and cheap so the garment worker is the
only point of the supply chain where the
margin is squeezed
and
you have this huge you know companies
going to the factory in bangladesh place
in order for 1.5 million genes
for
you know 30 cents each 50 cents each how
can you make it ethical i don't know
but also from the consumer point of view
is it really democratic to buy a t-shirt
for five dollars a pair of jeans for
twenty dollars
or are they taking us for a ride
because they're making us believe that
we are rich or wealthy because we can
buy a lot but in fact they're making us
poorer
and the only person who is becoming
richer is the owner of the fast fashion
brand
so that makes me a little bit angry
you spoke about a commitment to
trying and promise a basic living wage
what does that mean
how do you define a fair living wage in
bangladesh
you know
what does that mean and i have a pilot
project in three factories and by 2018
15
of your factories are going to have that
it's not good enough
it's not
it's very clear for us that what a
living wage is is something that the
workers should say and that's
incorporated that's incorporated in our
way of working how much yeah and that's
not for us to say some but we do an
assessment all the time
to make sure that it covers the basic
needs of the workers so it's i can show
you that later on
h m has mastered the model of fast
fashion becoming the second largest
clothing corporation in history
with annual revenue of more than 18
billion dollars
they are now one of the largest
producers of clothing in both bangladesh
and cambodia
sadly along with every other major
retailer i asked they declined all
interview requests for this film
[Music]
in cambodia garment workers have had
enough
recently taken to the streets to demand
a minimum wage increase in the country
[Music]
as protests continued workers were met
with violent crackdowns as police began
to open fire with live rounds
[Music]
a woman has been killed and several
people injured in clashes between
clothes factory workers and riot police
in cambodia
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
for two days
cambodia was a battleground the city of
phnom penh
the police the paratroopers
were brought in as if there were
war on the streets of philippines why
because workers in the textile industry
continue to demand
a minimum wage of at least a hundred
sixty dollars
slapped
um
today is the funeral
of
a factory
worker
he
was beaten to death
he had suffered
a lot
before his death
this morning
and he
had done nothing wrong
he among his
fellow
workers wanted
to have better living conditions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we will continue
this fight
so that all
cambodian workers
will have decent living conditions
the cambodian government like other
developing countries are desperate for
the business that multinational
retailers bring
because of the constant threat that
these brands will relocate production to
other low-cost countries the government
holds down wages routinely avoiding
enforcement of local labor laws
but because the major brands do not
officially employ the workers or own any
of the factories they produce in they
are able to profit hugely all while
remaining free of responsibility for the
effects of poverty wages
factory disasters and the ongoing
violent treatment of workers
the whole system begins to feel like a
perfectly engineered nightmare for the
workers trapped inside of it
you cannot fool us
and exploit our human resources exploit
our workers the workers will continue to
rise up
i called on the international brands
to put that struggle
into
dollars into pounds into euros
it translates
into human capital
it translates into
social responsibility of these big
corporations
it translates into economic justice
when everything is concentrated on
making profits for the big corporations
what you see is that human rights the
environment workers rights get lost all
together you see that workers are
increasingly exploited because the price
of everything is pushed down and down
and down just to satisfy the this
impulse to accumulate capital and that's
profoundly problematic because it leads
to the mass impoverishment of hundreds
of millions of people around the world
if you write to any of these companies
they'll send you their code of conduct
and it's beautiful and it says oh yes we
take responsibility for the conditions
under which our product is made you know
the product that you buy
all the factories where we produce we
require them to respect the minimum wage
laws you know all of the laws of the
country
to respect women not to hire children
no forced labor
no excessive overtime hours all that
stuff
but when we
submitted a bill in congress a few years
ago or worked we worked with people to
do that we called it the the decent
working conditions and fair competition
act
the companies responded in one voice oh
no that would be an impediment to free
trade we can't we can't have rules we
can't have we can't have that
they want to keep it with voluntary
codes of conduct now that you know
they've fought for and they've won laws
to protect
their stuff and their interests
but you know what about the workers the
workers are left with voluntary codes of
conduct and what we see in case after
case after case
is that those voluntary codes of conduct
are not worth the paper that they're
written on we need to acknowledge
particularly in the fashion industry
that human capital is part of this
miraculous formula
without human capital
without cheap labor cheap female labor
it would not be generating the profits
that it is
that needs to be acknowledged it needs
to be dealt with and those people need
to be rewarded instead of exploited
where is their piece of the pie that's
what we constantly have to ask ourselves
are those buyers immoral or do they just
don't or they amoral the system they're
working for the system that allows
companies to do this is amoral the
individuals concerned are simply
products in that system and having to
drive it through to its logical
conclusion what we need to do is change
the way those companies operate
operating within a system that only
measures profit companies have little
incentive to do anything other than to
make this quarter better than the last
no matter what damage is caused along
the way
as corporations that make up the global
fashion industry major brands as well as
seed and chemical companies are growing
today to reach unprecedented global size
and power
this mandate for profit at all cost is
beginning to stand in direct opposition
to the values that we share
richard wolf is an economist who after
graduating from harvard stanford and
yale became convinced that the real
problem is within this system itself so
america became a peculiar country you
could criticize the education system to
make the schools better you could
criticize the transportation system to
make that work better you could create
but you couldn't criticize the economic
system that got a free pass
you couldn't criticize just you know and
if you don't criticize something for 50
years it rots
it goes to seed but one of the ways a
healthy society works is it subjects
its component systems to criticism so
that we can debate it and hopefully fix
it or improve it or do better
capitalism couldn't be questioned
capitalism is the reason the fashion
industry looks as it does today it's the
reason why workers in bangladesh have
paid so little because if you're
operating in a capitalist system the
main thing you have to do is create
profit and you have to create more
profit than your competitors and this is
what drives companies to push wages down
and down and down like they don't cut
like companies don't go like fashion
retailers don't go to places like
bangladesh for any other reason except
they can get the cheapest labor possible
like there's no um collective rights in
regulations no trade union rights
there's a very very low minimum wage
there's no like maternity benefits
there's no pensions that is why the
fashion industry is in bangladesh
because it can reap the biggest profits
out of those people
that are making the close for them
before you can solve a problem you have
to admit you got one and before we're
going to fix an economic system that's
working this way and producing such
tensions and inequalities and strains on
our community we have to face the real
scope of the problem we have and that's
with the system as a whole
and at the very least we have to open up
a national debate about it and at the
most i think we have to think long and
hard about alternative systems that
might work better for the environment
the great threat is that capital must
continue to expand infinitely in order
to survive
it can't have any limits on its
expansion and its growth
the natural world clearly does have
limits there are very defined limits to
how much the world can sustain in terms
of production in terms of trade in terms
of transport and distribution and it's
quite clear that we've already
overstepped a lot of those limits which
is why you're seeing such stress in the
natural world at the moment
the system we live in isn't one that
most people want to live in i think it's
a system that makes most people very
unhappy and i don't think people want to
live on a slowly dying planet or to be
exploiting um you know their neighbours
so
i think i think we need
huge systemic change
if you don't change this system
you're leaving intact the
decision-making of these enterprises
which means a small group of executives
and shareholders are going to be working
in the same system subject to the same
pattern of rewards and punishments which
will sooner or later make them re-impose
their or elsewhere the very conditions
you're fighting against so stop this
stuff about improving their conditions
deal with a system or else you're not
serious
our economic system is one of consumer
capitalism and that's why
the government needs to have consumption
at very high levels
and why of course the corporations do
and why at some level most people then
buy into it you know i can't tell you
the number of people i talk to who say
well
but if we became less materialistic our
economy would tank
well they're right in some level because
our economy is based on
materialism it's based on these kinds of
values that's what it needs in order to
survive that's part of the fuel that it
needs
the problem is that comes at a really
high price
black friday's here can we go please go
go go go go
black friday shopping mani is still
playing out tonight at malls across
america in some places across this
country tonight it's as if someone
announced we're in danger of running out
of stuff and those who need stuff had
better go out and buy it now because
it's going away forever walmart doing
more than 10 million transactions in the
first four hours of the frenzy a record
15 thousand people at macy's in new york
city shoppers hung tough black friday
will be the single largest day of the
retail year certainly in the case of
macy's we'll do more business on this
day
than on any other day of the year nation
this orgy of christmas shopping proves
america is back we are once again
yes
oh yes
we
are once again spending money we don't
have on things we don't need to give to
people we don't like
u-s-a-u-s-a-u-s-a
u-s-a
[Music]
[Music]
i've kept my grip so tight
i won't let anyone get in my way
i want beautiful things
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
i grew up on a farm
married a guy that grew up on a farm
and those of us living on the farm and
playing you know live there it needs to
be safe for us too and and the new
chemicals that are coming out and the
intensity of the use
was just continuing to increase and
and then in 2005
um
terry started having some loss of fine
motor skills and this and that and come
to find out
he had a glioblastoma multiforme stage 4
brain tumor
and
at the prime age of 47 years old
and he died at the age of 50.
they gave us six months we had two and a
half years
and the brain surgeon
that worked on him we've you know
lubbock
has got huge cancer clinics and
a hub medical hub
uh we didn't have to go someplace else
to have a brain tumor surgery we were
able to stay right here because he does
so many of them he said that these kind
of tumors are found in men aged 45 to 65
that work in the agricultural
industry or the oil field
and so while i don't have a smoking gun
and a blood test that say
the use of
cotton chemicals and agricultural
chemicals directly led to my husband's
death
there's just too many linkages with his
father's death
growing up on a chemically intensive
farm we live in the middle of 3.6
million acres of cotton that use a lot
of chemicals and so
at that point in time
organic is was no longer important to me
it was imperative
it's imperative that we change
agriculture it's imperative
if we're talking about the long-term
sustainability and well-being of our
lives on this planet and our children's
lives on the planet that we have to
change
so
this is the beginning of a turning point
not just for you know a responsible way
of doing fashion but for a new way of
doing capitalism for a new way of doing
economics
i'm
i'm sure that we
we will see a significant change over
the next 10 years
whether it's in time or not is another
question
if you know martin luther king jr at a
speech in a brooklyn church he said that
what what america needed was a
revolution of values it needed to stop
treating people like things
needed to stop treating people in ways
that were just about profit but instead
to treat people in a real and human way
my god we can do better than this
if if what we want is to spread as i
would argue we do spread industry around
the world not concentrated in one place
let it let the benefits be shared
globally then let's do that in an
orderly
reasonable
careful way we need to
recognize that capital is just money
money is a means
and people should be accountable for how
it's used
we need to
celebrate
the creative power
of human beings and we need to talk of
creative work we must stop talking about
labor
we need to look at the
land as not a commodity
to be speculated on and traded but as
the very basis of our life as mother
earth
if you change all consumers into
activists
all consumers asking ethical questions
all consumers asking quite simple
questions about where their clothes are
from all consumers saying i'm sorry it's
not acceptable for someone to die
in the course of a working day we can't
just roll over and say yes have it do
what you like it's too important it's
too significant in industry it has too
much impact and effect on millions of
people worldwide and common resources
[Music]
will we continue to search for happiness
and the consumption of things
will we be satisfied with a system that
makes us feel rich while leaving our
world so desperately poor
will we continue to turn a blind eye to
the lives of those behind our clothes
or will this be a turning point
a new chapter in our story when together
we begin to make a real change
as we remember that everything we wear
was touched by human hands
in the midst of all the challenges
facing us today
for all the problems that feel bigger
than us and beyond our control
maybe we could start here
with clothing
[Music]
so
[Music]
i will protect your shadows
[Music]
mental health
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
is
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
in times of
restraints living in captivity
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sliding down
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you